here's the first time I've ever heard
you disclose it's like a dream of my
lighting into your eyes no
[Music]
well thanks for gonna be here I know
loft beautiful walk from my point of
view you're on this incredible role of
creativity like the last what year or
two you've got a new memoir out an album
out and another one right behind it has
it felt like a bursty was it or the kind
of business as usual it's felt like a
little bit of a burst I mean I know why
it's because wilcos been off the road
for the first time in a long time I
don't know if we've ever had almost two
years off of the road or a year and a
half at least
so that makes sense to me that a lot of
stuff would have kind of would
accumulate during that period because I
don't know what else to do yeah myself
yeah but my dad told me yeah before he
died he and well I'm sure we'll get to
that he said he said how old are you all
right I said I'm 50 and he said oh that
explains it he said 45 to 55 I was the
most productive I ever was in my life
huh so I kept I got four more years he
was on the railroad so for him well yeah
I don't know what productive met him I'd
be honest I really don't go I mean I
should have asked yeah he's to be coming
through in the book of the really
interesting guy it feels to me anyway
from the album end remember his his
death and his life is very much kind of
in your mind or sort of infusing these
things is it yeah and his death
coincides with me really wrapping my
head around writing about my life you
know
kind of getting serious about finishing
this memoir and you started before his
passing yeah yeah by the time I really
got around to writing seriously that was
the thing I was processing the most was
being an orphan yeah you know just the
reality of I guess you can still feel
like an orphan at 50 years old yeah yeah
you know our daughter Elena who you know
she I said there was a part of the book
that really moved me and I said I took a
picture of it and said she goes wow
that's his voice Oh which is not easy so
how was it writing prose after so many
years of writing lyrics and poems and
everything's a different different
feeling different process prose has
always been like a a phobia
almost like an irrational fear of not
doing it right
it's always felt more natural to me to
distill language into something that
isn't so rigidly specific but still
paints a picture you know like haiku or
something is like the ideal form of that
you know and lyric writing to me is you
know not just for the listener but for
me to sing it over and over and over
over long periods of time it's ideal to
have it be something where you can keep
coloring it in a little bit different so
we end up being much more interested in
them in the things that don't really
necessarily advance a story when you're
writing prose so you know you're telling
a specific thing you want it to be
really clear you shouldn't be Rauf into
like what type of spoon was sitting on
the table that was a real confident
because a lot of times when people are
first writing prose especially if
they're readers and little books what do
you do there's a tensing up you know and
and yours was it was natural and it kind
of it dressed really beautifully into
things and came back and I was I really
loved that it was oh thank was so much
like her and I learned a lot actually
especially about the we'll talk about a
little bit to create a processor and
uncanny writer about that kind of oh
thank you yeah I I really really enjoyed
it by the time I got confident about it
I initially started out saying I don't
want to have to have anything to do with
this and like I'd hired somebody to help
me write it and I was gonna do all these
interviews and take transcripts and
trying to like shape them into a book
and that's how the book kind of started
and that's where it's at for a long time
until it became really clear that
theoretically that should work but it it
was terrible it just like felt awful and
so in a pretty intense burst of like
just not wanting to have a book that
sucked i sat down and wrote it in about
three months like kind of rewriting took
some of the same shape of how the the
transcripts had kind of been organized
but then really sat you know thought
about how I wanted it to read and how
and I did read a lot of the sentences
and paragraphs out loud to myself when I
was working so it felt like
was able to say it you know it was
interesting because it you really in the
book and and I left it kind of the same
way I leave your record which is kind of
just feeling more capable of like being
a decent person somehow right now and
also that you know that one of the
traits in it that's really wonderful is
the honesty like you you start to go
somewhere and you go well yeah I guess I
need to
and somehow witnessing that makes the
reader feel more like yeah we don't you
know never would kill you to be a little
more honest or to look directly at
something so this interview won't just
be all praise we're gonna say go in
tonight well I don't I'm with that yeah
I saw me do sort of like the bio thing
but you grew up in Belleville Illinois
down himself can you kind of set that up
for us like what was it like what was
your house what was your day-to-day life
and one of the defining characteristics
of my childhood was that I was the
youngest of four by ten years so I had
the experience of being the baby in the
family but also being sort of an only
child because my brothers and my sister
were by the time I really have memories
they really weren't living at the house
bell bows like a kind of a dying
industrial town like a blue-collar
suburb of st. Louis a lot of people that
live there work at the chemical
factories and the railroads in the st.
Louis area when I was growing up it felt
very sheltered from st. Louis it didn't
feel like it was connected to st. Louis
in fact it was treated as a huge deal if
you were going to st. Louis and by the
time we were teenagers and driving to
st. Louis to go buy records our parents
and people our parents age we're like
wow you're going to the moon why do you
have to go to the moon to buy records
you know it was really really shocking
to them that you would do that willingly
not for a Cardinals game all right
were there signs of that there was a
musician there and the whole I mean
we're the early things that you can look
back and go yeah that's definitely a
budding young artist about to happen of
me yeah like trying to think if there
are any musicians in Belleville
like Carl he was pretty good I don't
know if I've ever seen myself as
anything other I don't know if I
pictured myself as being well I actually
I had no problem picturing myself as
being Bruce Springsteen but I'm
delusional I don't know there's
something like I don't know if that's a
that has anything to do with bail though
but in the book you tell story about
sort of you know the writing Born to Run
yeah well yeah in the fourth grade I
took I took a cassette that I'd made of
Born to Run I'd recorded off the radio
on Sunday nights they would play whole
albums on the radio in st. Louis and I
guess Born to Run came out they played
it in its entirety I recorded it or
somebody had recorded it maybe my
brother I don't even know how I got it
but it convinced myself that I had
written it and it was me and I took it
to school to show it off as part of
show-and-tell or something that this is
this is the record I just made when I
was a kid I had appeared where I thought
I had written Swan Lake
I heard it and I just insisted and my
grandma was like this it was so hurt
that she didn't believe me
uh-huh yeah there's an obvious benefit
to that I mean if you can't picture
yourself doing something like that it's
pretty hard to do right and it wasn't
necessarily picturing myself actually
writing born to run
but picturing myself being able to do
something that made me feel like born to
run or made me feel like well that's
impressive yeah that would be really
cool if somebody and apparently somebody
put their name on this and said they did
that a us or elsewhere you know
something was really interesting to me
as a teacher of writing because you
talked about how its act I guess
basically ambition is not only okay you
have you have to have it it's not it
shouldn't it's got kind of a bad name
but it shouldn't people mistake ambition
for career ISM or something less savory
then just wanting to do something good
you know one thing to be good at what
you do where I don't know something more
Craven or phony or something right but
even so promoting I don't necessarily
see as being
a horrible sin because I don't think
necessarily your output is self it's as
much as people was yeah because you
talked in there too and I love this
about how one of the pleasures of music
for you has always been the like I guess
the diminishment of self in the in the
process is that happening for you during
songwriting during performance both I
mean is there some and the bigger
question means when that self goes away
what is it that fills the gap you know I
think for me the process of writing or
the product you know being engaged in
the act of creating something in the
studio or anything even writing the book
from time to time I have a this
experience which is kind of what I crave
and what is the most sustaining part of
the creative process for me is like
feeling like I have disappeared like the
burden of my ego and all its
insecurities and all of its desire to be
seen a certain way has evaporated and
what I'm what's what you're left with is
nothing and and I think that that's
that's incredibly powerful to be okay
with to be in a position where you're
okay with being gone yeah but then that
thing also decides right I mean it were
it it's it's it kind of knows how to
proceed it somehow right yeah yeah which
is weird I mean it's not and I can see
how people get really mystical about it
and I'm not particularly mystical about
it and you know like all the universe is
speaking through me and like they're
like I'm a conduit you know I look at it
more as like oh your subconscious is
always at work and that's just kind of
getting out of the way and letting your
subconscious be a little bit more
forceful how do you get into that space
and what is it what how does it proceed
mechanically it's a lot less constant
when I'm working here I have really
wonderful collaborators and people that
I spend all day with Tom our engineer
and Mark
who manages the studio just kind of sit
around and don't really struggle too
much to put together an agenda of what
needs to happen but at some point it
just feels right to start digging into
something that presents itself as the
next task maybe it's a guitar part
or maybe it's finishing a set of lyrics
and then the next thing I know it's five
o'clock right but at home it's a lot
more it's a lot more sustained if I'm
like finishing words or writing lyrics
at home it's much more an uninterrupted
thing right here-there know we've talked
before about this you call it a lyrical
method mumble track so we you kind of
have an arrangement down and in you're
sort of right over there I guess singing
and that was really interesting to me
can you talk about that a little when I
first started writing songs and they
started being put out into the world
where people were gonna hear them and I
would I started becoming a little bit
self-conscious about how simplistic they
were and they were simplistic because I
wrote them really quick to have a song
and I didn't really write them down
I decided that if I could remember them
then other people could remember them so
I I tended to write really simplistic
things that I could remember easily I
just felt like I wasn't trying hard
enough and so when I started wanting to
write more and you know insightful or
ambitious lyrics it was really slowed
down the process because I didn't want
to finish a song until the lyrics were
finished and so I figured out a way to
around that at some point would be to
make the sounds and the rhythms that I
know I want to have there but I haven't
had time to put the words together for
it to be a finished set of lyrics so I
could keep working on the song until I'd
really completed the the environment the
landscape then I would have more of an
idea of what I needed to do to not break
the spell of what the melody and what
the landscape was able to contribute
musically because that's the whole point
I'll just be writing poems or it would
just be you know writing prose or
whatever if it was something you could
just tell with words
so I've always kind of tried to err on
the side of the music doing all of or
not all of but most of the emotional
heavy lifting you know like I've had
this experience and where I've like
things have slipped through the cracks
many times over the years where I have
records and if I go back and listen to
him there'll be a turd in the punchbowl
a song that has like a lyric that I'll
just go oh no I broke a spell but but I
I didn't see it at the time that's the
name for the next album the turd in a
Punchbowl yeah there's the outtakes but
so but in that process in the book you
say this really amazing thing which is
that you're kind of humming along and
then words start to come out of the
stone a little bit you recognize certain
phrases right but they're often are
mostly not nonsense they're they're
actually meaningful or or I think giving
yourself license to just make sounds and
not be self-conscious about it tends to
free your subconscious up to say things
that you would be too embarrassed in
some cases to admit right so at times
there have been if I'm really in a
particularly tuned-in state of mind with
a particular piece of music there have
been times where whole lines or whole
verses come out almost fully formed and
I just kind of keep them and just kind
of work around them so it's gotta sound
good a process of really trusting that
if you kind of just surrender a little
bit of control than what what comes in
will be informed somehow or coming from
a deeper place I'm trying to get into
this a very similar such state of mind
to our conversations you know that you
and I have some times where I I did not
compose sentences to say to you or I did
not premeditate what I want to
communicate but I have feelings that
come from the way you and I interact I
want to have that conversation with a
piece of music is what I'm trying to do
and I like I think everybody improvises
all the time it's a it's a it's a type
of improv improvisation that requires a
little bit more time
than what people standardly think of is
improvisation right for me I I for
whatever reason I don't have the ability
to actually do that in real life I'm
away I feel like I'm a little more
constructed than I would like to be but
with writing prose and especially the
revision part this more honest part will
lurch forward and so that's actually I
mean it is definitely self receding but
the the other thing that comes in is
much more frank and a little less polite
and will kind of go where it needs to go
and that for me is the real rush this
one right and that's like that's what
happens when you know you your
conversations aren't the same with
everybody you sit down and talk to I
mean you take into account a lot of
different information like whether
somebody's listening to you that's as
close as I can get to explain it to some
people that think of it as being
something more magical right we're doing
kind of miraculous things all the time
as caring humans when you allow yourself
to have an intense conversation with
somebody and and I've discovered over
the years that not everybody likes that
but I gravitate towards it and I
gravitate towards people that are
invigorated by that type of I often
think that that process of being in a
work of art has something to do with
awareness like in other words in in pro
in fiction the the big game is that
you've written a bunch of stuff and you
think you know what it means but it
might not mean what you think it means
and so every minute you have to
reinvigorate your awareness of what
you've just done and then respond to
that and it sounds like it's similar and
although I think you guys songwriters
have always so envious because it seems
like it's fresher and a little more
fearless and like you know if I make a
mistake in my room if nobody knows about
it but you guys are you know there's an
open energy kind of yeah I mean it's
it's important to like let go of the
fear of finality or the fear of
something being rigidly presented as an
idealized work of art for songs for me I
don't go back and listen to them very
often I'm playing them I'm performing
them all the time so whether I
consciously try to or not they evolve
and there
kind of evolves and so that I'm I'm just
making when I'm making a new song I'm
aware that that's still that potential
is still going to be there for the most
part so in that case how do you when
you're here working on something in
you've been in it for a few whatever
days weeks how do you make the decision
that that's the version that we're going
with that seems to me like a Rubik's
Cube that would torture you I'm a big
believer in deadlines I think they're
really helpful in and there's a joke
that we say all the time in this studio
is like we're thinking about things that
will not affect sales here like spend a
long time stressing out over a hi-hat
sound or E or something like that and
it's nobody in the hopefully nobody no
one in their right mind is gonna listen
to the record for the hi-hat sound
I mean it's intuitive it's it's an
intuitive thing but generally I feel
pretty good about setting a deadline for
myself or knowing that there's a
deadline and I do exercises like this
all the time with even shorter deadlines
you know like I have 10 minutes to write
a song I'm gonna write a song let's see
how see how much of a song I can write
in 10 minutes and so it's like how much
of an album can I put together with what
I have here today right to work with
kind of a constraint cuz any anything
can be an album anything can be a song
so it's like what makes warm and now I'm
like what was your sort of selection
criteria what's the heart of it there
was kind of a free-floating period while
Wilco has been on hiatus where you know
I I was coming up to the studio every
day and I'm just kind of amassing this
dozens and dozens of songs that I really
wasn't sure what they were for or what
kind of home I could find for them with
a Wilco songs were they songs for my
band with Spencer for Tweedy and
somewhere in the middle of that process
I started touring a little bit on my own
and going out and playing so shows with
just an acoustic guitar for some reason
I just kind of got Restless and started
playing new songs every night I would
kind of introduce a couple of new songs
to this set and and see how they felt in
front of an audience I hadn't done that
in a while but it's a really good thing
to stay connected
- like can I put this song across with
just an acoustic guitar and with a new
song and then no-one's ever ever heard
no one's ever heard so I started doing
that and a lot of times you play a new
song and you can kind of tell that
there's their people kind of tuned out
you know and then there are times you
play a new song and it feels like you've
just bared something about yourself and
people were really paying attention and
you can feel that I don't know you just
feel that connection you feel like you
do when you're really being listened to
by a friend or something you can feel it
in the room you can feel it in the room
it's just like it's just kind of a
sensation and and you can hear when you
listen to other records with people you
know like if you listen to a record with
your best friend and you both love that
music it sounds better then when you
listen to it with somebody that doesn't
like music you know after a couple of
tours like that I kind of sat down and
said whoa I I know what would make the
best record it would be putting all of
the songs that I've kind of played in
front of an audience and I felt that
that coming back for me
and that's what these songs on more arm
are here's the first time I've ever
heard you disclose it's like a dream of
my lighting into your I know
[Music]
all my life I've played a part in the
bouncer but the ones I'm taking a moment
to apologize I should have done more to
stop the war so I'm sorry I leave behind
betrayal of songs the duck is glued to
the bladder son I lost my way but it's
hard to say what I've been through
shouldn't matter to you
oh man so drunk he can't understand told
me once hold in my sufferings the same
for everyone he was right that was wrong
too
[Music]
thank you just play the rest of the
album come on come on oh yeah so so I
mean this might be an unfair question
but can you talk us through how that
little beauty came to be it's such a
perfect little song and I was listening
to it the first time and I'm literally
like walking through it like a poem like
oh I don't know I'm not sure is that
true and then at the last moment it just
pops Oh wonderful I mean it started on
iPhone probably the acoustic part just
coming up with the like kind of a court
this does chord voicings felt exciting
enough to me to document on my phone and
then it lived for a long time where it
was just like Oh much more subdued like
vocal performance and it always felt a
little bit ponderous like that you know
a little I don't know a little less
urgent right but I think the lyrics were
probably started sometime right after
the election in 2016
trying not to just feel complete despair
and rage and trying to take some stock
in my own role in whatever environment
has been created for a lot longer than
just someone like Donald Trump right you
know just trying to remind myself that
the world outside of the United States
has endured a lot of trauma beyond what
I was experiencing and this was like
sort of normal for a large part of the
world to have this feeling of despair
this feeling of being so out of step
with the values of someone in power you
know or that there were no values for
someone in power and then there's
enormous damage going to be done and
you're helpless and to stop it but yeah
so if I'm not mistaken that has a
throwback to something that's in the
book about a guy kind of in rehab kind
of calling you out on suffering and your
your relation to suffering yeah yeah
when I was in rehab you you know you'd
sit in these group therapy sessions and
you'd go around in a circle just
horrific stories you know like I was
beat with a extension cord and thrown in
a hot bath you know scalding hot bathtub
and just people that had just come
through so much and then it would get to
me and I'd feel like I was really too
sad to get on a plane and go do a press
junket for my new album you know I was
in the hospital for a very legitimate
mood disorder you know a level of
discomfort that had debilitated me but
by if you're if you're trying to
empirically measures like suffering it
didn't come close to the suffering I was
hearing about and I had tried to share
that feeling of oddly enough inferiority
well the way I was the mentality I had
it was almost like I'm trying to win
suffering or something you know I was
competitive or something but it wasn't
really it was more like a seer Lee felt
like I was in the wrong place and I
tried to express that to one of the guys
that I'd heard tell a pretty horrifying
story I believe the story was that the
first drink he ever took in his life was
when his dad killed his mother and had
told him this will help you forget and
his father was convinced it and that his
9 year old son wouldn't remember him
killing his wife if he if he got drunk
right away instead of reaching out and
consoling I was like like I'm I I don't
feel like I have I belong here I feel
you know like this horrible thing to say
you know like I was trying to be honest
about what I was thinking but I wasn't
reaching out you know in a way that was
helpful to him but he reached out to me
in a way that was helpful
shut the [ __ ] up we all suffer the same
your suffering is relative to your
ability to tolerate pain and he was
right and I was wrong
it's like I was wrong to work so hard to
absolve myself of something that wasn't
that wasn't the point that song does a
really amazing thing that I think we've
talked about before and then a a
powerful work of art is able to
contradict itself you know kind of have
two things at once and you just say yes
that's the contradiction is actually the
truth right you know the truth is vast
and that's the thing that was actually
sort of daunting to me writing a book
was coming to terms with that I don't
know if I'd ever really thought about it
in those terms and how how vast the
truth is you know because almost any
story I wanted to tell in this book I'm
50 years old almost all the all the
people are most of the people involved
are living and they're their version of
it was weighing on me you know you know
like how accurate is this to someone
else's choosing not to mention how vast
each moment is for is as far as like
describing a scene yeah moving the way
we rewrite our own memories you know
that scientists now say you take a
memory out and you when you put it back
you micro adjust it to fit your current
view of the world right and thus
overwrite it you know right yeah that's
that seems totally legit yeah in the
book there's I'm a like of amateur
guitars and there was an amazing part
where you talk about why you prefer an
old well I guess older strings you talk
about that because that was a deep I
thought I always feel like I talk a lot
about this guitar in particular in the
book because because I've used it so
much and I'm and I've used it so much
because I feel like it is it has
established itself as much as my voice
as as being a part of my identity as as
an artist I think it matches my voice
I'm always really confused by a brand
new guitars that ring like a like a well
tuned piano or have like tons of
sustained and overtones and things that
sound like a really chipper and alert
person
and this this guitar is really
unambitious and a lot of ways you know
different from the type of ambition we
were talking about before but just
unambitious about being a virtuoso or it
doesn't have a lot of sustain my voice I
don't tend to be able to hold a lot of
notes with a lot of confidence so there
are tons of things I could I could talk
about it all day it really opened up a
can of worms but yeah they're they're
just tons of things about it that feel
like when I stop singing the the guitar
is still maintaining that something
about that Tambor you know like I do
Wetmore right and then there are guitars
that I have tried to play with and sing
over in my life where I felt like I'm
really trying to sing like a different
person or you know it's not even a
conscious thing even you know just like
sort of slightly adjust to try and fit I
don't know a guitar doing better than me
I love that because one of things with
my students what I talking about is you
don't get to eradicate any putter so if
you can't alter your fundamental voice
right so then everything you're doing in
terms of structure and form is just ways
of making that part of yourself play
nicely with the other part and also that
level of self-awareness it took at some
point for you to say yeah I don't
this new strong guitar is pushing me out
of the vent right and well yeah and
that's the other side of it is specific
aside from being an old small like a
small body guitar that doesn't have a
like a really wide range like similar to
my voice when you put new strings on it
it's really unhappy and it really put it
in too tight of a suit or exact thing
it's like you know yeah it's like a kid
in Sunday school or somebody but also I
think I've talked to somebody about you
in this context you're a great guitarist
but you often will I mean you're not
you're not shredding all the time yeah I
mean that's a conscious I don't yeah I
wouldn't think of myself as a great
guitarist I feel I've know like I've
tried to learn how to do a lot of things
in my life on the guitar that I'll never
I'm aware I'll never be able to do oh
and like what show us no I mean I play
with I play with you know no
fine and and and I've played with a lot
of musicians and I love a lot of
musicians that are just so conversant
with the guitar for it to be I don't
know to me it's just like it seems
miraculous to be able to think that fast
and things like that
but I spend a lot of time with guitars
and I've been able to figure out how to
make them do some things that I feel are
unique to me to help me get a point
across so one time when I was visiting
you here you were out of the room and
Tom told me something like has he said
that you had the uncanny ability to kind
of pre imagine what certain combinations
of say guitars and amps sound like do
you and I do have a really good memory
and for stuff and you know you think
with this amount of gear there's so much
gear up here but you'd think that I
wouldn't have a conversant relationship
with all of it but I'd say a bulk of it
I'd really do and so I'll just remember
certain characteristics about certain
things and I don't really consciously
try and do that it's just like I'll just
think of a sound I think I would be
great if it had this like sort of
nasally rude person coming I always
think I'm as people people as like like
what's that guy doing that you know or
you know what I mean I always I always
picture a band inside the speech you
know like inside the speakers and I
always want to know what what's wide
that guy stick around why is like why
didn't he go away you know after that
chorus or whatever so that I think about
things like that but but yeah and
they'll be like you know that's not
gonna be rude enough just by himself
he's gonna need one of these you know a
fuzz pedal or something and sometimes
it's just luck but but I think for the
most most part I can get pretty close to
the sound I'm picturing and does that
memory work backwards in time so if I
name a song on an album and say you can
you kind of reconstruct the setup to get
that guitar tone or we document document
a lot of times but I think most of the
time I can kind of guess do you think
that's true tom
yeah yeah I can like what's up we've
recorded like four or five years ago
like oh that sounds like the brown base
with the b15 or what you know it'd be
fun to exist in it that well it is the
problem is you have to spend time like
communicating with normal people
you say when somebody says how are the
Cubs doing it's like you know they're
all gonna die somebody yeah that's
that's a party bus they might be dying
right knee oh no well they might be Jeff
Tweedy can you talk me through sort of
like three musical moments that you went
through as a kid that transformed your
your approach or your your my approach
or like your your love for it yeah how
did it come alive for you in its certain
inflection points I fell in love with my
sister's 45 so my figured out later that
it was my my aunt and my sister had
combined their 45s into 145 bucks
they're roughly the same age my sister's
a little bit older than my aunt my
mother and my grandmother were pregnant
at the same time and then had kids that
went to high school together and you
know so anyway I digress but so they had
the the birds turn turn turn single that
would be one big moment of deep
affection that felt like you had to call
it love you know what I call it you tied
that in with the structure that it was
kind of a weird not versed Corti thing
well it just seemed to create its own it
created its own internal logic and and
Sonic universe in ways that other music
hadn't yet for me you know like other
things sounded a little bit more like
I'd understood where they they were
being performed with with instruments
and there were people singing and and
that one had like the 12 string guitar
sound which was not particularly common
to me
or I think that's one of the things that
was appealing about it when it came out
even those electric twelve-string guitar
which was so sort of novel roger McGuinn
voice was something I could really
relate to because it's it's sort of meek
and not particularly soaring as an
instrument but there are harmonies so
but I wasn't really aware that that was
there were a lot of harmonies I just let
this one guy could make his voice sound
like like a you know I don't know
something richer and more spiritual like
something I don't know you know the
lyrics founded you know I sounded like
something I could abide by that makes
sense seasons go bright so that would be
one I don't know if I write about in the
book I had a friend growing up who lived
a couple houses away from me and his dad
was a farmer and they had they actually
moved back to the farm and started
farming again at some point when I was a
little bit older my mother had talked to
his parents and decided that we're gonna
get Jeff and rusty back together you
know like Jeff go visit the farm and
spend the night out there and hang out
and work on the farm a little bit and
see what farm wife's like by this time
in my life I was maybe eight or nine my
normal weekend ritual was to watch the
evening rock concert shows there was
like Don Kirshner's rock concert rock
concert written and Midnight Special and
and these were really miserable things
for me to miss and so we were gonna camp
out in his yard and I begged this farmer
to bring a TV out to our tent with an
extension cord so I could watch Midnight
Special did he do it and he did it he
did it but my friend who was my friend
when I was little but he couldn't stop
making fun of every single person that
was on the TV and like you know what
these freaks and and he was racist and
it was just like it was just a horrible
experience it was one of those
experiences where I realize music sounds
different when you're like you have the
wrong like companion
ie rusty yeah rusty was not having it I
think that stuck with me for a long time
that there was something communal about
the ability to even absorb things that I
was cared about it I was like good at it
by myself
you know as like really sustaining and
perfect can listen to almost anything
and enjoy it we're talking on the phone
while ago you said something really
beautiful about how I felt paraphrasing
but this song isn't complete until
somebody hears it and for you that's
part of it is it I mean you you need
another consciousness to put it together
it's there's a you know there's a
broadcast there's a way I'm transmitting
this thing and for to complete the
circuit someone has to like you know put
it back together in their consciousness
and we don't all see the same colors you
know the same way we all don't hear the
same frequencies so a lot more is
relying upon that person's talent as a
listener and and intent as a listener
then I think we normally give credit to
yeah and I've noticed even being in your
audiences that one of the things is
happening is and I don't want to like
make it to New Age but but I felt that
there's like a feeling of mutual
consolation like people people come to
your music I think with this do sort of
a different set of hopes than in many
cases like there's some sense of like
trust and of some kind of looking for
reassurance is that does that seem like
that does seem that way to you and is
that interesting you helpful to you
terrifying I don't know if I completely
am able to put myself in the audience
that way right I know on stage I really
want it to be great and I wanted I know
no I don't want to let people down I
don't like feeling like like we let
people down and at the same time that's
a different criteria than you would
think it would be that doesn't
necessarily mean giving everybody
everything they want and to me it means
I'd be letting them down if I wasn't
sincere if
I didn't acknowledge them as being a
part of it in some way I don't know no
that's beautiful yeah one things in the
book that I loved was you you had sort
of self-identified one of your artistic
gifts or maybe personal gifts is that
you were vulnerable from the young age
and you didn't care like you're
basically okay with it
that wasn't that's not my brand
vulnerability what does that mean it
means you you feel something then you
don't edit it or you know I mean what's
I don't know the best I mean the best
thing we've been able to do to put it
together is that I was you know as a
baby of the family and as a almost like
an only child and one of the things we
also haven't addressed yet is the fact
that I was my mother's primary companion
you know I was very much a mama's boy
and sort of unhealthily relied upon as a
joy bringer for my mother right and and
at the same time it was very easy for me
to bring my mother joy she just adored
me so I think in a very early age that
put it in my head that my every passing
thought was interesting in some way that
my mother would be fascinated to know
that I felt like I couldn't draw as good
as the girl that lives up the street or
something I don't know that was indulged
no one and and and at the same time my
mother was very insightful and intuitive
she was a brilliant woman who never
finished high school
you know she had ambition probably
artistic ambition that was unfulfilled
so there was a lot of vicarious I know
encouragement to be an open wound yeah
like she would if it was up to my mother
I would have worn like like a zoot suit
to school or something I would have worn
a beret or you know like I would have
been much more flamboyant or I don't
know whatever that cloistered sense that
I got from her probably made me just
think that everybody must feel like I do
and so what's what's the shame and and
crying in front of everybody when they
obviously all cry right yeah no let me
segue to I had a chance to interview Joe
Biden last year and it was kinda you
know you interview with him and you're
like oh Stefano and then halfway through
I just I blurted I said so Joe what the
hell is going on in this country and he
started laughing and he told us but what
do you i guess what do you think's going
on and how does it intersect with your
artistic mission if if it does someone
has figured out how to weaponize
victimhood in a way that's very very
difficult to combat when someone has the
sense that they're a victim and in this
case I'm talking about fairly privileged
white people they're really dangerous
because when you are convinced of your
victimhood the other side doesn't isn't
human anymore they've done something to
you intentionally and they deserved
punishment you know and I think it's
it's how a lot of really dangerous
movements have started out of the sense
of victimhood that can be kind of like
stoked
so you're saying victimhood at the top
and but also that victim sense of
victimhood resonating with people who
also feel a sense of victimhood
underneath is that that well a lot of
the people that are at each other's
throats in this country have way more in
common than they think they do and in a
lot of ways they've been kind of like
they've been conned into fighting over
scraps you know I don't think that a lot
of people can even imagine imagine some
of the wealth that that people enjoy and
at their expense I grew up in a place
where I can really empathize and
understand all of the profiles you see
of Trump voters and stuff very much
resembles the atmosphere I grew up then
I can totally see those people believing
someone has consciously done this to
them that the immigrants are going to
have you
whatever whatever whoever is being
blamed I think they can buy it so then
with that understanding how do you how
do you approach your work like is there
is it is there a purpose and music in
that kind of a set up well for music
more than a lot of other art forms and
for a working band like Wilco and like
myself as a solo performer you still get
to provide this one communal experience
that still happens outside of sporting
events and you know like there are other
things you know but it's a really
important one to me to get people in the
same space singing along with each other
having an atmosphere an agenda that is
outside of all of their concerns yeah
and at the same time one of the benefits
of like a church type environment was
always that it was a place where you
could go and feel a part of something
feel feel a part of something bigger
than yourself I don't know to sort of
lose yourself and find yourself at the
same time you know you lose your all the
burdens of yourself and find yourself
where you actually are and that is as a
part of a much bigger bio mass you know
a part of these these humans that are
walking this earth at this moment you
know you know Zadie Smith was I heard
her talking about
I think her in-laws are a little bit on
the right and she was there some how do
you relate to him he said we kind of
imagined that every person has many many
persons inside them and then at
different moments different people will
step forward she can relate to the one
who's the great-grandmother a wonderful
grandmother and in the same way you
start hearing music and maybe you could
that music loving park could step
forward and it's complicated though
isn't it it's really complicated and
it's hard to watch cruelty
happen and not be angry or feel like
there's something more that you should
be able to do and in a lot of cases
there is you know and there's a minimum
that you can do just like vote you know
or at least at least try and weigh in
when something is directly in front of
you that's a little bit that's one step
above that
and then there's the frustration where
to draw the line between having a life
that you enjoy is that's joyful and and
that you share with your family and how
to tolerate the knowledge that they're
suffering in the world for a long time I
felt like one of the big problems for
humans is that we haven't evolved as
fast as our technology has evolved to
absorb all of the suffering in the world
all at once you know a hundred years ago
you would find out about the suffering
in your you know like the problems or
the the trauma or the consequences of
some dispute in your community and you
would maybe find out about something
that happened overseas or somewhere far
away over a long period of time you'd
get the news that it happened it's done
there's nothing you can do about it
right now we know in real time you know
like things that are happening all day
long every day yeah it sets up that
weird moment where you're experiencing
an authentic moment of joy that might be
hard-earned and if you wanted to you
could go over and just bring in
something that would [ __ ] it up
basically right yeah I mean it's I know
from having kids that it is it's it's
the next generations aren't any they
haven't evolved yet they're still
suffering from it there's doings you
know there's anxiety that goes with it
you know yeah so like trying to figure
out what how to have a good day yeah
yeah well and also that you know the
idea that having a good day is actually
empowering because you have a good day
or a day of presence then if something
actually comes into the domain you can
take care of it whereas if you're
distracted and agitated you can't let me
ask you this you when you look at your
your career and your development as an
artist first of all what do you think
you've gotten better at over the years I
honestly feel like I've gotten better at
everything
the bar was so low you know from the
beginning to now steady improvement on
all fronts yeah I mean I don't know I
think that's the the thing that it's
most satisfying to me is is coming up
here and realizing oh I I just worked on
a guitar part that I could
never played four years ago or is there
stuff as you look down the line what do
you what do you want to get better at or
what is what's still under your skin to
get done oh I don't know I just have a
ton of energy for it I don't know I
don't I don't question it that much I
mean I'm on a need-to-know basis with a
lot of things and and and like like
there has never been a steady
progression towards virtuosity like but
there's a steady progression towards
being able to hear more elaborate things
in my music and and do it intentionally
then there I'm also confronted very
often with I hear something but I cannot
play it I can't do it and working by
myself so much over the last eight years
or so has forced me to go well I can
wait for like three weeks somebody I
think you know Pat will be here or
somebody will be here that can play that
on the piano or I can try and figure out
something that will work yeah you
mentioned doing like faux steel guitar
around a lot of yeah that's the toe
that's one of the defining things of
warm for me musically is that that began
to be a thread through the record is to
have this sort of pedal steel sound that
they don't know how to play the pedal
steel and I don't know how to I didn't
know how to make a guitar sound like a
pedal steel consistently luckily have a
studio and a lot of time on my hands I
made an effort yeah speaking of the
studio King kind of like what I wanted
where are we here we are in the Wilco
oft we've had it for 20 years or so what
was the first album that you did here we
did parts of mermaid Avenue to here we
moved in right around the same time we
started on Yankee Hotel Foxtrot a little
bit before that so Yankee Hotel Foxtrot
out a lot of it was recorded here over
the years almost everything since then
has had every record since then it's had
at least part of it done here I would
imagine maybe
wilco the album might not have had that
much done here it was originally a
friend of my wife's had come by to check
the place out and he had a band and the
rent was a little bit too high for his
band and he told her that I should check
it out it was originally rented as a
place hopefully where we could rehearse
up until that time we had had our stuff
in storage spaces and then you'd have to
go drag it out and we went to a
rehearsal space and and I hated that
yeah so I wanted to have a place where
everything was set up all the time it's
like a paradise in here now it is it's
transformed quite a bit over the years
but this is the last six or seven years
has really been I think where it's
really shaped up into studio slash
museum kind of thing guys yeah so you
record I mean this kind of guide us from
what we can see this here is really
interesting it's basically designed
around Wilco and luckily will cause a
six-piece band so most bands or other
people when they come up here to record
they usually fit in to do it at least
some somehow right right but um that
would be my location which with the amps
I prefer to use generally that's Nels
Klein's station and the base area is
John's area right here and then there's
a drum booth that you can't see that's
kind of to keep a little bit of that out
of everyone else's microphone because
drums are awful you don't get anything
else no I'm just this is obviously the
keyboard world and Patton and Thomas
sitting back Darren and then the control
room is not really a closed control room
like a lot of Studios traditionally
would have that can be problematic if
you're worried about sounds bleeding
into each other's microphones but it's
okay if you're trying to get a
performance from everyone beautiful and
I can see your your frame picture of Don
Rickles which is what's it's important
it is important in every artistic
venture there should be there's a Don
Rickles and there's a Bob Newhart framed
on top of art console do you ever find
it sounds like maybe not but do you ever
get to a place where your talent needs a
little jump-start like a little reminder
of why you
love this stuff and if so what do you
what do you do uh I don't know if I
don't feel like it's so deeply ingrained
in my idea of Who I am I don't
necessarily feel like my talent needs a
jumpstart my ego definitely is is less
consistent mhm you know and I feel like
that's good I feel like it's it's kind
of been helpful to me to be restless and
dissatisfied you know you want more so
than you do more kind of right yeah I
want to I'd love it if you made one
great thing and you were really happy
with it and everybody loved it and then
you felt like you were great because
that you did that the rest of your life
that was my original model was all my
neurosis would go away if I just write a
book and it actually got worse exactly
yeah now you know you have to make
something that competes with something
everybody already told you they like
sure to fail yeah it's impossible ii
think both the memoir and the album if
i'm reading correctly are full of this
incredible familial warmth that pursues
you and your kids can you talk about the
way that that has sustained you over the
years and what at this point no after
the kids are pretty much grown I really
credit my wife with with um with that
being the case that I'm that I'm 50
years old and I have a marriage that has
stayed together and and two kids that
like to hang out with us that are young
men amazing and really smart and
thoughtful people and and it's a it's it
is a family that likes to spend a lot of
time together on one hand Susie one of
the big things Susie did that I'd never
experienced was we ate meals together
you know it's like it's very simple it's
as simple as that you know
yeah I actually that when you were
saying what what could we do about how
what the hell is happening like we got
more people eating meals together
I think things would be but much better
and to me amita rock concert is kind of
like
a certain type of meal together yeah you
know my family ate I was I would take
tup from school we drive through the
McDonald's drive-through my mama dropped
me off back at home and she'd go back to
work and and we even on Thanksgiving it
would be go make yourself a plate all
the food be out all day long and you go
make yourself a plate Suzie the first
time we went to my folks house for
Thanksgiving she was like what the hell
does that mean what's that what do they
mean make yourself a plate it means that
the food is ready if you want to eat and
just like you mean we're not gonna sit
down together so that was a real
revelation and it really it should be
like in my opinion rule number one for
anybody that has a family you know like
you would never find out a lot of the
things you find out about your kids
without putting yourself in proximity
you know it's just not gonna collectible
proximity so then yeah every night yeah
yeah I mean I've motivation she was a
force of nature I think she know
impressive and wonderful and artful and
know this is the way it's gonna be yeah
yeah because only an idiot would not
want to do it like the right right do
you mean you're gonna go eat in the
basement come here yeah so that I really
benefited from her her her strength and
her ability to kind of show me the way
from behavior that I didn't have modeled
for me and then the other thing is that
for all of the problems and and flaws
that my parents had and for like then
the problems that my brothers had and
the distance I'm naturally inclined to
feeling like wanting to get along with
my family you know one thing to be
connected and loving my family they just
like think that you know that's not uh
note that's on not a unusual thing at
all right but it's been kept really
separate from rock for a long time
because Rock was built on this
generational divide and the generation
gap as being a defining characteristic
and it's extremely to me extremely
counterproductive to think that you
could have a youth revolution without
allowing yourself with with with an
older generation right yeah I think
that's one of the things that that's in
your work that is really um actually its
radical because the idea that someone
would be completely edgy and also at the
same time completely open to the idea
that love as well you got and family of
course is important that's for me it's
been really meaningful and I think I'm
grateful
yeah yeah I think it's there's a lot of
nihilism and like a punk rocker stuff
that I grew up with and a lot of it's
done a lot of damage like you've done it
damage the idea of like being able to
play your instruments it's not damage to
this notion of getting along with older
people or you know there's a lot of
anger and and and things that are
difficult to control and harness in a
positive way and I don't know what the
point is if you're not going to make an
effort to do something positive I read
one critique it was an Irish journalist
but she was saying that that the knee
ilysm that started in art is kind of a
dead end and actually what's happening
on the far right is they're turning it
on us a bit because if the only sort of
cool artistic stance is to disregard and
distrust and sneer then that's the one
position you can't critique when
somebody starts sneering and right
discarding the truth
you can't possibly resist him and be
cool so this is sort of opening a door
for another way of thinking about art
yeah Susie had a rock club for years in
Chicago lounge acts and and it was
really enlightening we were like I never
gave you a third musical experience
right so this would be my third musical
experience that I think really
transformed me and that is like I always
assume that the bands that I I bought
records by that we're like super gnarly
like intense almost demonic sounding or
you know like just the edgiest scariest
bands they'd always be the sweetest guys
they'd always come in and sit down and
and end up being friends with them even
though I was I would always assume that
they would never like a band that played
sort of country music or whatever
and that was wrong too you know because
I never really ended up meeting very
many musicians that I felt were very
good that didn't have a pretty broad
appreciation of other people's music
even even if they seemed very
specialized and and dug into their
particular genre they generally are
pretty they're pretty into music you
know and so that was really enlightening
I really love that idea that this guy
ended up talking to him and he's like
singing about you know babies being
ripped apart or so and that's an
expression it's cathartic thing that
they're doing that you know but they
collect stamps and they're really into
you know talking about I don't know
Joseph Campbell or something like that
you know like they have a broad palette
of things they're interested in they
just selected to do it in that one and
and as we got older a lot of you know
like a lot of them have you know really
nice families really wonderful families
and really loving commitments to their
spouses and I like normal people doing
extraordinary things yeah you know what
they're talking right this has been so
much fun
thank you always great to talk to you
you too